okay so really kind of going through DC
rebar it's one of the things I'm going
to be doing while we're kind of waiting
for a lot of the more recent stories to
wrap up is to go back and cover some of
the stuff that we just haven't had a
chance to do yet kind of get caught up
on some of the other stories that were
left behind or are things that we simply
just you know kind of skipped over for
example we kind of we skipped over
Action Comics all you want so it is
really kind of weird because we we
messed it up we goofed
I was so wrapped up with the idea of
like who is Clark Kent that we just
didn't do the path of doom like it's
Superman versus dudes and really
Superman and Wonder Woman versus
doomsday but it's actually kind of a
really cool story because it really kind
of brings in the idea of mr. Oz and
actually gives us an indication of who
he is which is really sort of
interesting here but the fact remains
with regards to to the path of doom this
again is really like one of the first
major story arcs from classic Superman
had come into the new 52 and this is
actually the story where he sort of
introduces themselves to the world so in
terms of the chronology this actually
comes before pretty much everything
we've done with regards to Superman
rebirth so far but the fact remains here
what this does is set the stage for who
Lex Luthor is and what Lex Luthor is
about remember the new 52 Lex Luthor
became a good guy you know following the
events that were ever evil it was kind
of DC reforming his character and just
simply asking the question but what if
Lex Luthor was not The Namesake villain
of Superman what if he was a friend like
what if he was an ally and so they began
the process is sort of reforming him
which led us to where we are right now
with regards to you know Lex Luthor and
so on so what is up here is again this
really kind of picks up with the idea of
Superman and his family kind of you know
moving and getting themselves settled in
but then ultimately they're met with the
appearance of Lex Luthor donning his own
Superman outfit because remember the new
52 Superman had died by this point and
so the idea was that Lex Luthor thought
that there should be some kind of
successor and in his mind he looked at
the idea of Superman as his friend and
said I'm going to basically live up to
the legacy that he created and so what
this does is it brings the classic
Superman and the new 52 Lex Luthor
directly into conflict with one another
now again this is really kind of cool
because from the universe that classic
Superman comes from you know everything
before the new 52 Lex Luthor was a bad
guy and no matter what Lex Luthor did if
you put on the appearance that he was a
good guy it was always a facade it was
always a joke it was always basically
some scheme where he had an ace up his
sleeve
and then he would just pull off the
entire cloak once it was all said and
done and say this is
a grand master plan ultimately come out
and reveal himself to a been a bad guy
the entire time and so the idea is that
this classic super man does not know the
life and times of the new 52 Lex Luthor
he doesn't know what he's about he
doesn't know his history doesn't know
his past he just sees a Lex Luthor and
says no matter what universe I'm in that
version of Lex Luthor is always going to
be a bad guy and in this instance he
immediately distrust Lex Luthor now
again we know the road that this leads
to right like we know it eventually
leads to a place where the two of them
basically become allies I wouldn't say
they trust each other but it is
beginning to move in that direction
where you know classic Superman isn't
really looking at the new 52 Lex Luthor
as an inherent bad guy so again it's
really kind of cool now the conflict
between the two of them is pretty much
to be expected I mean it's really just
like you're a fall Superman you're not
the real Superman that kind of thing the
idea of classic Superman tolling Lex
Luthor I know you're a villain I know
your intention is to do bad things now
of course this also comes with the first
appearance of Clark Kent who of course
we know who he is right now I'm not
going to ruin it for you guys who
haven't seen those videos yet if this is
your first one
but we're again we had that in the
playlist the whole storyline that runs
through all that stuff so I won't spoil
it for you but it's a pretty cool reveal
but that remains what we end up finding
out here is that the new 52 doomsday the
version of doomsday that we saw facing
off against new 4uq Superman is
basically having its carcass
you know transported to a particular
location now this is funny because this
is DC kind of coming back and saying
look guys we could have handled the new
52 Superman versus the new 52 doomsday a
little bit better I mean it really could
have been handled a lot better because
that story came out of something where
as part of something called Superman
doom and Superman dude was actually kind
of a twist on the original Death of
Superman story instead of doomsday and
the new 52 Superman fighting each other
and the new 52 Superman being killed by
doomsday instead what they did is they
actually kind of changed it up and they
made the new fidgety Superman into
doomsday he was kind of infected with
the doomsday virus so to speak and begin
to metamorph into doomsday now this was
disappointing to a lot of fans because a
lot of people had looked at the
character of doomsday and said okay this
is a legacy character whatever doomsday
is introduced into a story it's only for
one purpose that is to either kill or
severely injure whoever it is that he's
fighting against not for that person to
become doomsday on their own because of
some weird you know mutation or
something like that and so
people were pretty miffed about how that
story ended and so what this is designed
to do was kind of harken back to the
idea of the original Death of Superman
story that's the reason why we have this
version of doomsday dressed in this
green guard the way that he looks is
because it's literally supposed to be a
harken back to the original Death of
Superman story when that version of
doomsday first appeared in DC Comics so
it's really kind of cool to see those
things kind of match up against each
other now keep in mind this is classic
Superman versus new 52 doomsday he's
never fought this version of doomsday
before and the coolest thing about this
is that all of this is being watched by
mr. Oz now this is the closest that we
get in terms of what mr. Oz looks like
my money is on mr. Oz being Lex Luthor
that was a really good point that sell
over at Comic top Hatzalah where
colour-pop said mr. odds is probably the
classic Lex Lucas the classic villain of
Superman who somehow made it into the
new 52 or is existing outside of space
and time we don't know where he is but
that's probably Lex Luthor it looks a
lot like him but there's no guarantee it
could be virtually anybody we have no
real clue who it is this point for all
we know it could be war Shaq who was
like resurrected by dr. Manhattan and
Rorschach's a bad guy or something like
that we have no idea which I'm hoping
Rorschach comes back love his character
he is amazing anyway the fight between
doomsday you know nudity doomsday and
classic Superman is really intriguing
because Lex Luthor does what he can
where he can but he's got a mechanized
suit his suit is not designed for the
purpose of being able to go toe-to-toe
with someone as formidable as doomsday
it takes organic strength and abilities
to go against someone like doomsday
because of the size and power and so on
and so forth the other half of this is
that the way this new 52 doomsday was
originally done you know the way that he
was first introduced in Superman doomed
he was a little more strategic he was a
little more intelligent insofar as
doomsday it's not a genius or anything
like that but originally in the classic
DC classic doomsday was just this
mindless fighting beast I just wanted to
destroy things and tear things up the
new 52 version of doomsday was a little
more thinking he was a little more
strategic he would use the environment
around him to his own ends he wouldn't
just punch and punch and punch and punch
he would go after those who were close
to Superman he would way to wage a war
on multiple fronts a psychological war a
physical war and so of course while Lex
Luthor is kind of resigned to getting
you know Clark Kent out of the way and
getting you know Jimmy Olsen out of the
way the battle between a classic
Superman and
doomsday is pretty intense but the other
half of this one of the reasons why this
story is so cool is because it focuses a
lot on Lois Lane and Jonathan remember
classic Lois Lane is here alongside
classic Superman and they have their son
Jonathan now John does not know about
the whole Death of Superman event he
doesn't know all that stuff you know but
Lois remembers that well and good I mean
she remembers cradling her husband in
her arms as he lay dying she remembers
the whole aftermath all that kind of
gets stubborn so in her mind this seems
like just a repeat of the things that
have happened before this seems like a
repeat of the fact that her husband is
going to be killed by doomsday now this
is why things are so cool and this
writers story was done so well because
we as the reader sat down and look at
this and said is it true like is this
possible could something like this
happen would we end up seeing classic
Superman die yet again now in the back
of our mind in our heart of hearts we
kind of knew that wasn't going to happen
just because of the fact that as far as
we were concerned we were like why would
they bring him back just to turn around
and kill him in his inaugural story you
know they'd be kind of weird and it
would actually be a little bit weak but
it's still kind of a cool scenario and
so kind of a cool situation and that's
really the legacy of the original Death
of Superman story living on everytime
Superman fights doomsday one of them
ain't going to make it out alive
and it usually ended up being Superman
he died at the hands of doomsday so
again it's really kind of a cool thing
it's sort of interesting to see all this
come together now of course at this
point we actually see a end up seeing
the introduction of Wonder Woman and
that's one of the coolest things because
remember at this point right now Wonder
Woman is aware of the fact that the new
52 Superman is dead and the classic
Superman is here like she was aware of
the fact that he's there that he's
trying to be a hero so on and so forth
she doesn't know the ins and outs and
the intricacies of his life but she does
know that he is trying to be a good guy
and so again by virtue of the two of
them basically teaming up this prison's
of scenario that we haven't really seen
before I mean we saw it in the new 52
but we haven't really seen the fight on
this scale we haven't seen an adaptation
of the original fight between the
original Superman and the original you
know doomsday what's Wonder Woman thrown
into the mix and that's one of the
coolest things here because I feel like
DC has done an amazing job really kind
of depicting Wonder Woman as this just
hardened warrior I mean this woman who's
both soft and gentle but she's also
going to like beat the hell out of
whoever it is this she's fighting and
it's really kind of cool to see that
sort of scenario play out you know it's
really
cool to CDs to team up with one another
now somebody keep in mind is that wonder
woman's tenure here is pretty
short-lived and the reason why is that
while she would be a pretty huge aide on
behalf of a Superman one of the things
that Superman realizes is that doomsday
can sense Kryptonian DNA his son John is
part Kryptonian which means that if this
version of doomsday is more strategic
than the classic doomsday the classic
Superman thought but it means that this
version of doomsday would go after his
son if for no other reason than to
basically you know kind of create a
distraction or the very least to make
Superman fight a battle on two fronts
the whole Jonathan hostage any number of
things but the idea is to basically find
his family get them to a safe place and
then go back and fight day and so what
is up happening is Wonder Woman holds
off as best she can
and she does a pretty darn good job at
it to be honest to you I mean it's
pretty cool to see her facing off
against doomsday with her sword and
shield
and handling her own just like anybody
else could but the idea here is for
classic Superman to basically tell
Wonder Woman get my wife and son to the
watchtower of the Justice League get
them out of here and get them to safety
I'll take care of this on my own now of
course he does for the most part I mean
you know Wonder Woman gets them out of
there when a woman gets them to safety
but the cool thing about this is a
constant Superman recollects on his own
battle with the classic doomsday and he
says look the last time when I fought
doomsday from my universe I died I went
to a healing major it she had a yachtie
anyway uh he's like basically for all
intents and purposes it seemed like I
died he practically beat me to death the
idea is to not take that same Road this
is compounded by the fact that again
this version of doomsday is a little
smarter this version of doomsday is a
little more strategic and so the idea is
to try to find a way to overpower
doomsday will also get doomsday to make
mistakes so that's one of the big deals
here that's one of the big interesting
concepts now the other half of this are
the actions of mr. Oz and this is really
kind of cool because mr. Oz actually
sends his own guys in for the purpose of
capturing doomsday now again we don't
really get any answers in terms of why
he's capturing doomsday in terms of why
he wants doomsday but we know that he is
and that's really the common theme with
mr. oz he's very cloak-and-dagger very
enigmatic we don't know who he is we
don't know what his goal is we don't
know if he's Friend or Foe you know he's
just kind of a guy who's there and he is
wildly mysterious since the reason why
there's so much speculation on what's
going on with him now of course the
forces of mr. Oz are over
and almost immediately and that's
exactly what we would expect but what
this does is it leads to classic
Superman leading doomsday to his
fortress of solitude now this is cool
because what he does in the middle of
all this is he realizes okay look I
cannot continue finding doomsday forever
that was the first mistake he made and
that's one of the things that he said he
says look when I thought doomsday in my
universe we fought until a standstill I
didn't know who he was I didn't know
what he was capable of I didn't know
what he was about there came a point
where I realized I could injure him but
by then it was too little too late but
doomsday is every ounce as powerful as I
am and he will always keep coming back
which means I can fight him forever and
he'll always keep coming we have to find
a way or put him in a place that he
can't attack anybody and so the initial
intention is to actually confine him to
the Phantom Zone and that is a genius
idea is one of the coolest ways to deal
with doomsday as I say okay Bob let's
just put him in the Phantom Zone let's
just put him in a dimension out there
somewhere that nobody can ever escape
from and that's exactly what happens
here I mean basically attacks doomsday
hits them with the Phantom Zone
projector and believes to basically risk
doomsday away and so the cool thing
about this is that while the day seems
to be saved and while this does set the
stage for the questions of who is Clark
Kent Wallace it's the stage for the
questions of what will happen with
regards to how Lex Luthor and Superman
relate to one another
ultimately what we end up finding out is
that doomsday was not whisked away to
the Phantom Zone
instead doomsday is basically in stasis
and that he had basically been captured
by the forces of mr. Oz that in the
split second between the time that the
the Phantom Zone projector was initiated
and the time the Superman believed he
won doomsday was captured and taken away
now this begs the question why and
that's one of the cool things about this
and it's one of the other reasons why I
really wanted to kind of cover this
story is because mr. Oz really kind of
closes this out by saying doomsday is
mine now that begs the question is mr.
Oz at war with like dr. Manhattan is he
creating and creating an army of his own
because we know at this point he now has
doomsday we know that he had mr. Mixel
pedelec we know that he has Tim Drake is
almost like he's collecting pieces he's
collecting characters who have been
extremely intricate and important to the
entire DC landscape over the course of
their publication history and if that's
the case then is he collecting pieces
for an army of his own do they have a
particular role to play is there a
reason why mr. Oz kidnapped
Tim Drake instead of Dick Grayson or
Jason Todd or any of the other members
of the bat family who have all been a
huge part of Batman's mythos these again
are kind of the questions that are being
propped up and it's actually really cool
to see in terms of how all this comes
together and how it meshes and how would
it eventually lead in to the idea of
Superman versus dr. Manhattan but
without being said guys if you are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]